At least 1 student asked, "At the end of this course,
will we be able to write JavaScript programs?"
This question sounds simple, but actually it's surprisingly complicated.
Yes!
By the end of this course, you will have written a few simple, but honest, JavaScript programs.
Lke the implementation of Euclid's algorithm that you've already done,
over the course of the next few units,
you'll get 1 or 2 more chances to write JavaScript--simple JavaScript programs.
But mostly, we'll be doing that to make sure that we understand the correspondents
between JavaScript and Python.
One of the things that we'll hint at as this course progresses is
that those 2 languages are actually equivalent in a very strong theoretical sense.
Anything you can do in Python, we could also do in JavaScript and vice versa.
Now when people say, are you familiar with JavaScript?
Have you written a long JavaScript program?
They're probably talking about the way JavaScript interacts with a web page,
uses the document-object model to draw flashy animations or change what's displayed
to the user.
We're not going to cover that in this class.
That's more of a presentation or user-interface issue.
In this class, we want to understand the theory--the nuts and bolts--
behind various programming languages.
So we're not going to talk a lot about how to draw buttons
or how to make special text effects,
instead we're going to talk about how to interpret functions and integers and strings.
What if the user's Java program is recursive?
Could we still handle that?
And once you can handle a language that has variables and recursion and rich control flow
and a plethura of meanings,
it turns out that all computer science formal languages that have that power--
they're all equivalent.
Anything that you could do in C, you could do in C++ or Java or JavaScript or Python.
So you could work your way up to writing the flashy buttons,
but it's not a topic for this class.